good evening members and welcome to this
southeast area planning committee
meeting on wednesday the 21st of july
2012
my name is councillor vanessa bell and
i'm the chairman of this committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members and the republic the set up for
the meeting has been
designed to mitigate the code therefore
then i asked full president to work to
the british polls the greater council on
29th later in 2031
in the interest of member and officer
[Music]
please reference your current right
number when referring to the agenda
papers keep your contributions
clearly concise as possible and ensure
your microphones remain on when not
speaking
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the adjective papers
regarding the different levels
within the chamber and advise that the
fire exit
is the door behind this top of the
stadium here and that is also the exit
by which we leave
off to make sure members i just have
some feedback at the last week's thing
to help after very valiant question
about
councilman having called in an
application and
yet not to be here to speak to it
so i would take some information some
advice from
some quote monitor officer on that and
he advises that
if a similar situation would have
happened again which i don't think it
would
be returning to the next meeting i think
in september
that council fluke or any other
councillor
could approach me as chairman and ask
to speak on the application that they
have called in
obviously they wouldn't be able to vote
but they would be entitled to
take a lobbying perspective and speak
and indeed members that is what i intend
to do this evening
because i called in this application
so in order to avoid any
possible concerns around
pre-determination i won't be voting i
don't know but anyway
there's a chair but i will be speaking
on a lobbying from a lobbying
perspective
thank you item too apologies
[Music]
thank you thank you it's recommended
that the minutes
i just raised 30 minutes it's
recommended that minutes of the meeting
were held on the close
to disclose the existence of nature only
disposable peculiar interests
other pecuniary interests will normally
accumulate interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda and in regards to paragraphs six
to eight inclusive contractors
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
shouldn't need arise throughout
community remember
that's a standard
you madam chair just that i'm a member
of business county council and they're
not being consulted on anything to do
with highways
and i've got no killing of interest or
any interest tonight
mr lewis and he was my architect
okay thank you i should practice
um i do know them i'm not very good with
names i recognize them so
so now i will say i do know of them but
only because they're a local business no
other
relations thank you i think remember
it's very difficult sometimes
when we live in reasonable small sales i
think it's
quite unusual
is
updates the public comments received in
relation to
the original
planning commission was granted earlier
this year for a number of extensions at
the site
this current application seeks to vary
to condition two of the previous
commission
which states that that the development
must be carried out in accordance with
the approved plans
this application now seeks permission to
install rental ratings
on the top part of the sea wall in
between two buildings
thanking a slipway the old clubhouse and
the otter hut
the iron fence would measure 1.1 meters
above the existing sea wall
and will version 2.2 inches in total at
the point closest to the old clubhouse
and 2.5 meters in height overall by
measure next to the off the hub
the fencing would span the vector of the
wall which is approximately 5.9 meters
between these two buildings
the new wall time gate is also proposed
in front of the existing club
no other amendments suddenly made to the
original proposal
this is the location plan showing sites
and aerial views located
along the sea front is the southeast
side of berlin
[Music]
these are the previously approved floor
plans and showing no
festival ratings on top of the sea wall
in the area in bread
[Music]
and then the proposal plans um just
showing the location of where the
fencing would be located
he previously approved elevations and no
effects in more operations to the sea
wall
and the composed elevations showing
where the radians would be located
5.1 meters high above the symbol
it should be noted that during the
course of the application
amended plans have been received so that
um
close board fencing which for part of
the original submission
is no longer proposed above the existing
people
the proposed ratings would be an
acceptable quantity and maintain the
views of the yesterday
and would therefore therefore preserve
the character of the area
the application is therefore recommended
for approval thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
good evening councillors as adjacent
neighbours
residents at eastern both house and
owners of the award-winning alterheart
we accept the proposed ratings of
improvement on the web or barrier
but we still have some great concerns on
to application
we are very relieved to see the
conservation officer
has recommended large-scale drawings
showing adequate gaps between the
uprights and let the work to be of an
acceptable quality
however our concerns are as follows one
now that the proposed ratings are to be
attached flush
to the front of the sea wall with no
helpful step up for all these intruders
there is no need for the barrier to be
eight foot high
surely a sensible compromise would be a
total guarding of about
six foot two
any future railing needs super careful
design without compromising the otter
hub building
avoiding abutment to the existing copper
flashings and gushers on the otter hunt
three the end railings returning onto
the otter hut
would cause serious problems for any
future maintenance work
a neater solution might be to craft
panels with central support
four we feel the proposed design is very
unimaginative with 58 verticals along
five and a half meters with a hint to
the waves this is a conservation area
with a view to the river which belongs
to everybody
that walks the key at the very least it
deserves the work of the created
armstrong to hand forge the slope
railings five
the metal should be stainless forged or
better still bronze
consideration to the salty air
six and really importantly if permission
is to be granted
we would be looking for assurance that
nothing in the future
can be attached to the railings to
obscure the view from the key
thank you for your time and i hope you
can bear our serious comments
in line tonight
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay good evening hello clubhouse
home is both from the maritime lifestyle
and where we're at the history and
culture of birmingham
learning jeremy himself is a trustee of
the vanderbilt restoration foundation
charity
this proposed railing is a small part of
the preferred house
is
[Music]
this is
[Music]
risk of trespassers being seriously
injured on the slip point
the initial platform houses the workers
to confidence
this year dropped to the scene let's see
the applicant is naturally able to
protect the powerful equipment
the initial application for the weather
hall fence drew a lot of criticism for
infrastructure views through to the
river
we of course sympathized with this and
delivering intentions or was in the
upset
liaison for the planner and the nei
anton harrison
relationship with the communication area
the ea also supports a proposal
and when we will obtain the correct
building permits
the applicant works with the vast master
platform in essex
which will ensure that the railings will
be created at the highest quality many
thanks
thank you very much excellent timing
again
spoken um you
recommendations
could i just ask some questions in
regards to the
railings i'm a little confused really
question one is is the slipway a private
slipway
and the railings themselves are going to
be
eight foot high is that really are they
that big
are they really eight feet high that's
the application
so so the reason they're that high is to
stop
people climbing over or is it to stop
vandalism
why are they so high we don't know
that's a very good question okay so then
we can just
go back so assuming that
the railings are there are they they're
open are they gated ratings can
then have access to the subway
this is like 20 questions or something
i'm trying to establish is why why i
mean the reason we're having ratings on
the ratings is to protect
the new the the clubhouse the load
the boat
okay so eight feet raining is a
protected boat is that
okay thank you
cancer passengers asked a lot of what i
was going to say and
i don't have a problem with the ratings
because we all are unfortunate to know
that we have
we have been put up further down and
it's totally ruined a lot
of you are not beautiful but that's a
different
issue and i do have an issue with the
height
i'd like to commend the applicants for
actually working and changing the
original
design but i should take on board what
the
speaker actually said the lady and i
think
for it is a conservation area and i
i really feel that i admire what the
owners are trying to do
and i think they need to protect if the
boat or whatever the vanguard is moved
there or for whatever reason they have
i totally understand that um but i do
have an issue with the height
um and i don't know if there's anything
we can do because
really i'm gonna look to mr lee because
i just think it's too high but then
again i don't know how i could put that
in
as a planning season a lot too mr lewis
[Music]
um
it's an interesting point it's
and you know that would
that that thought process
though you know there is a point you
know
cited in a conservation area members as
decision makers need to consider
just going back to the height if
somebody had a garden fence
and they wanted an eight foot high fence
we will be screaming saying that's far
too hot
surely so i think that the height is a
problem
i think the railings are probably valid
and the security
and also to stop people down the slipway
the other thing that really does concern
though is the fact that we're shutting
you know hopefully not and we can
stipulate this but we are not in any way
shutting off the view
for people to see the river so those
railings certainly do need to have
something
we need to put something in place to
make sure that something isn't pinned
to those railways to cause obstruction
for people actually
uh thank you um
this is difficult and i'm just wondering
if the applicant would be able to go
back
and consider reducing them by a minimum
of
possibly two feet um i do share a
concern about the height
and totally what i've said previously
chairman is that i understand but it's
just too
high and it is changing the whole of our
conservation area i noticed that mr
house and our conservation officer said
it was
acceptable i can't remember becoming
down the height
so forgive me i don't know if you
actually mentioned that if anybody can
assist me on that i think the design was
something that i felt it was acceptable
um but i do have a problem with the
height manager i'm sorry to go on about
it but i can't think of another way of
saying
that in planning terms
[Music]
um presuming uh this is above the city
what we've
still access and if it's not
high enough people can climb over if
they're saying not supposed to see what
no cancer
no cancer hell the design is such that
the
railings have bucked the seawall on the
sides
on the key side so therefore there would
be no
leverage for anybody to get a footing in
order to climb up
well they could get in from the sea
[Music]
um
for the owners of them to actually
maintain their property so is there some
way that
there could be some understanding or
agreement or something where
um if there was maintenance that needed
to be done access would be possible
otherwise how would any repairs be done
unless you had a boat
i mean there would be access because
obviously the owners will need to have
to access the slip right and come back
because the concerns
and so it part of the wiring very
important
conservation area which is the area that
we're thinking about now
sure and my feeling is that
berlin deserves better very important
conservation area
very
really i think his baby summed it up
immediately
the issues um
scale and bulk and design as concerns
so really manager will be just
and compromise here there is no major
objection as such
it's just some tweaking is
for the equation so
any challenge to that through the
conditions would
be unbeatable forever
to actually be looking to change the
fundamental aspect of what this
application is for us um
once again for example you know i would
tell you
to approve for views before i think and
be very careful about giving
directions
[Music]
[Music]
is
would be that perhaps
would have a think about reducing the
height uh maybe ensuring or giving some
insurances
that there would be no obscured
obscuring of the babies and um
you know and allow maybe should
maintenance be needed to the office hut
and access would be run something like
that perhaps
[Music]
uh
so
regarding that so i wouldn't
you know
obviously members consider that the
height of the railings have to
definitely
happen in the conservation area um
that's what they need from that
objective that has some
planning basis in the thought process
thank you very much
it's the height and i can't remember
exactly it's not full because it's just
the height in the conservation
area yeah i mean you made a very
valuable point chairman
in the fact that it is it is lovely down
there and we've got the wild currency
and we've got some superb buildings down
there
and it really needs to fit in with what
we've got there
sadly we have railings further up that
don't and hopefully we can adjust that
necessary issues another time but i
think it's really important for burnham
to make sure and this district that we
look after around conservation areas and
as we've said
and it's down to the applicants and the
architect if they could then consider
coming back with lower ones i don't
think the most probably will be
an issue but i think everybody needs to
understand that it is hateful it's hard
[Music]
[Music]
so always in favor
is
so the application is refused
thank you so that brings us
[Music]
is